[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Der Murat hat sich gewünscht,
dass ich noch eine richtig weihnachtliche Wintertorte mache.
Dann habe ich mir gedacht:
Ich habe doch jetzt echt schon viele süße Rezepte gemacht.
Es wird mal wieder Zeit für was Herzhaftes.
Und da fiel mir ein, den Letter Cake,
also diese Cream Tarte,
habe ich im Prinzip schon oft süß zubereitet,
aber noch nicht herzhaft.
Daher gibt es heute eine Cream Tarte,
also einen Letter Cake.
Nur heißt er nicht Letter Cake,
weil ich keine Buchstaben machen werde,
sondern eine Form,
entweder einen Stern oder einen Weihnachtsbaum,
also so einen Tannenbaum.
Ich weiß es noch nicht.
Jedenfalls ist da die Basis ein Mürbeteig
und dieser, wie gesagt, herzhaft.
Das Ganze kann man sich vielleicht nicht so gut vorstellen.
Also ich muss auch sagen,
dass Josh und Murat dagegen sind
und sagen, ich soll lieber was Süßes machen.
Aber ich glaube, das Ganze schmeckt dann
wie so herzhafte Cracker,
also wie so eine Vorspeisenplatte einfach.
Man hat so eine Fetacreme
und ein bisschen Gemüse mit drauf
und diese herzhaften Cracker.
Ich glaube, es wird ganz gut.
Wir werden sehen.
Am Ende dürfen sie probieren.
Ja. Jetzt mache ich erst mal den Mürbeteig.
Dafür verwende ich
250 Gramm Vollkornmehl,
250 Gramm Weizenmehl,
250 Gramm kalte Butter,
ein Ei,
einen Teelöffel Salz,
etwas Pfeffer,
jeweils einen Teelöffel Rosmarin und Paprikapulver
und vielleicht brauche ich noch ein bisschen Wasser.
Also ich habe jetzt gedacht,
weil es eben herzhaft auch wird,
nehmen wir mal Vollkornmehl noch mit rein.
Und den Mürbeteig könnt ihr jetzt
entweder mit den Händen zubereiten
oder einfach in der Küchenmaschine
oder mit dem Handrührgerät.
Und hier müsst ihr jetzt eigentlich groß nichts beachten.
Es kommen alle Zutaten in eine Rührschüssel.
Ich habe jetzt hier ein Dinkelvollkornmehl
und ein Weizenmehl.
Ihr könnt aber auch nur Dinkel benutzen oder nur Weizen,
was ihr möchtet.
Wichtig ist nur, dass die Butter noch recht kalt ist.
Also ich habe sie jetzt gerade vor zehn Minuten
aus dem Kühlschrank raus zum Zutatenrichten.
Dann ein Ei dazu für die Bindung.
Ihr könnt das Ganze auch vegan zubereiten
mit veganer Butter.
Lasst das Ei dann weg
und nehmt einfach ein bisschen mehr Wasser.
Das geht auch.
Jetzt natürlich würzen.
Ein bisschen Pfeffer,
etwas Salz
und ich habe jetzt hier noch
die Gewürze Rosmarin und Paprika.
Paprika gibt halt auch so ein bisschen eine Farbe mit dazu.
Und dann könnt ihr den Teig kurz verkneten.
Da ist nur wichtig, dass ihr nicht zu lange knetet,
auch mit den Händen, dass er einfach nicht so weich wird.
Aber, wenn ihr es in der Küchenmaschine macht
oder mit dem Handrührgerät, geht das ganz gut.
Und vielleicht könnt ihr ein bisschen Wasser gebrauchen,
falls er zu trocken ist.
Muss aber nicht sein.
Ich nehme lieber den Spritzschutz.
Denn ich habe gelernt
aus meinen Fehlern.
Also am Anfang sieht es noch sehr trocken aus.
Aber die Butter muss sich jetzt erst mal verbinden.
Und, wie gesagt, vielleicht ein bis zwei Esslöffel Wasser.
Ich werde sehen.
[Musik]
So ist er jetzt perfekt.
Ich finde, der hat auch echt eine schöne Farbe.
Es sieht aus wie so ein süßer Mürbeteig mit Zimt.
Aber nein, er wird herzhaft.
So.
Und durch das Rühren wird natürlich wohl oder übel
der Teig ein bisschen warm.
Deswegen wird er jetzt gleich noch mal gekühlt.
Und ich mache das nicht immer so als Teigkugel,
denn da dauert es einfach zu lange,
sondern ich drücke den Teig einfach schön flach
auf einem Teller,
decke ihn ab.
Und jetzt kommt er so für eine Stunde in den Kühlschrank.
Und ich kann mich in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal um die Creme kümmern.
Da mache ich nämlich eine Frischkäse-Feta-Creme.
Für die Frischkäsecreme nehme ich
drei Knoblauchzehen,
800 Gramm Schafskäse,
1 Kilo Frischkäse,
Olivenöl,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Also, wie gesagt, entweder einen Schafskäse
oder Hirtenkäse
und Frischkäse.
Beim Frischkäse habe ich jetzt so die Doppelrahmstufe.
Ihr könnt aber auch einen fettreduzierten Frischkäse benutzen.
Das wird jetzt sozusagen eine helle Creme,
also diese Feinkostcreme, die es im Feinkostladen gibt.
Da mache ich auch gern immer eine Abwandlung
mit getrockneten Tomaten oder Paprika.
Jetzt will ich sie allerdings hell behalten,
damit es eine weiße Creme wird.
Ich werde jetzt zuerst mal die Knoblauchzehen pressen
oder hacken oder reiben.
Das könnt ihr machen, wie ihr möchtet.
Und das sind drei schon recht große.
Drei große oder sechs kleine, würde ich sagen.
Den Hirtenkäse oder Schafskäse zerbrösle ich so.
Das geht auch so ganz gut.
[Musik]
Ja, das wird schon eine ordentliche Portion.
Dann kommt da jetzt der Frischkäse rein.
Ich hoffe, das gibt jetzt keine Sauerei.
Und Olivenöl für den Geschmack
und auch für die Konsistenz, muss ich sagen.
[Musik]
So. Dann ein bisschen Salz nur,
aber wirklich nicht viel.
Denn der Hirtenkäse oder Schafskäse ist ja schon würzig.
Pfeffer und jetzt alles verrühren.
Ich mache es kurz mit dem Handrührgerät.
Ihr könnt
– ja, nehmt ein Handrührgerät
oder eine Küchenmaschine.
[Musik]
So. Aber ich finde, so sieht es schon super aus.
Also hier ist eigentlich nur wichtig, dass die Creme
fest genug ist, dass ich sie später mit dem Spritzbeutel
praktisch aufspritzen kann,
aber halt auch nicht zu fest.
Ach! Ich werde es probieren.
Ich denke, einen Frischkäse hätte es noch vertragen.
Mein Gefühl sagt: "Nimm noch einen Frischkäse."
Also nehme ich noch einen Frischkäse.
Weil das erste Gefühl ist immer so das richtige.
Und wenn ich zu viel Creme dahabe, ist es ja nicht schlimm.
Denn ich kann sie ja weiter benutzen.
[Musik]
Willst du sie abschmecken?
>> JOSH: Ja, kann ich machen.
Es ist eigentlich ein bisschen früh dafür, aber...
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht? Deswegen.
Es ist so früh
für so viel Knoblauch.
Aber ich packe es hier auf die Brezel.
Es ist halt bei uns noch recht früh am Morgen.
Aber komm.
Hier, Josh, gönne dir Knoblauchcreme.
>> JOSH: Mmh! Okay.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Schon saulecker.
>> SALLY: Schon sehr gut.
Okay.
>> JOSH: Man schmeckt den Knoblauch.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen.
Also die werde ich jetzt abdecken.
Abdecken ist ganz wichtig.
Sonst riecht der ganze Kühlschrank nach Knoblauch.
Dann kommt das in den Kühlschrank
und ich kann direkt mit dem Teig weitermachen.
Denn dafür muss ich mir jetzt eine Schablone bauen
oder basteln, ausschneiden.
Und ich gucke aber erst mal,
welche Unterlage ich später nehme für die Präsentation.
Und dann mache ich mir eine Tannenbaumschablone.
Das hier ist die Unterlage.
Auf der werde ich später den
– mh, die Vorspeise
präsentieren.
Und hier habe ich jetzt mal eine Schablone gemacht
aus Backpapier.
Und zwar sieht die so aus, also ein Tannenbaum.
Der passt dann auch so ganz gut drauf.
Ich denke
– ihr könnt ja auch einen Stern machen
oder eine andere Form.
Ich denke, das passt so ganz gut.
Und jetzt kann ich hier den Teig ausrollen.
Hier ist jetzt im Prinzip einfach nur wichtig,
dass der Teig gleichmäßig ausgerollt wird auf 5 mm Stärke,
damit er zum einen gleichmäßig durchbackt
und man eben auch diese perfekte Optik halt auch bekommt.
So. Einfach auf ein bisschen Mehl.
Und jetzt könnt ihr entweder Abstandshölzer nehmen,
also zwei Hölzer, die 5 mm breit sind,
und hier hinlegen, mit dem Ausrollstab drüber
oder ihr nehmt direkt einen Ausrollstab,
der eben schon die integrierten Ringe hat.
Also da könnt ihr wirklich das nehmen, was ihr zu Hause habt.
Hauptsache gleichmäßig.
[Musik]
Und dann gern noch mal mit einer Palette einmal drunter,
damit es wirklich gar nicht klebt.
Perfekt!
Es wäre jetzt natürlich ideal, wenn es zweimal drauf passt,
aber ich glaube, nein.
Nee, nee, nee. Es passt einmal
und dann muss ich es ein bisschen quadratischer schneiden.
Doch, dann wird es. Ja.
Und jetzt einfach darauf achten: Auf der Silikonmatte
nicht mit einem scharfen Gegenstand schneiden.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach so ein stumpfes Messer.
Es ist zwar auch scharf,
aber es schneidet praktisch die Matte nicht durch,
weil es eben Kunststoff ist
und man sich nicht damit schneiden kann.
So mache ich das.
Jetzt ziehe ich das aber erst mal rüber auf die Backfolie
mit einem Tortenretter.
Denn sonst zerstöre ich es.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich gedacht, ich nehme Backpapier,
damit es besser hält, aber ich glaube,
ihr nehmt wirklich einfach normales Papier,
weil normales Papier besser dran haftet.
Und jetzt hier einmal drumherum schneiden.
[Musik]
Also, wenn ihr sichergehen wollt, dass euch der Teig reicht,
dann macht ruhig eine etwas größere Menge.
Denn ihr seht ja schon,
man hat ja auch ein bisschen Verschnitt.
Und
ich muss jetzt auch gucken,
dass es noch reicht zum Ausrollen,
wobei ich glaube, ich könnte die Mitte ein bisschen größer
vielleicht sogar ausschneiden.
Hier noch.
Weil das ist halt eine Form, da ist halt wirklich
– die Mitte ist dann leer,
aber man muss es natürlich trotzdem so ausgerollt kriegen.
Daher.
[Musik]
Und aus dem Rest kann man ja immer noch Cracker machen,
also Kekse zum Tunken.
Ja.
So ist es gut.
Und das kommt jetzt hier
auf ein kleines Blech,
darf aber noch kurz in den Kühlschrank oder Gefrierschrank,
bevor ich es backe,
damit es beim Backen einfach schön die Form behält.
Ich friere es generell eigentlich immer ein.
Aber ich weiß, dass nicht jeder ein großes Gefrierfach hat.
Ich meine, ich habe auch einen normalen Kühlschrank,
aber ich habe halt immer ein Fach leer für solche Dinge.
Und wenn nicht, packt es einfach in den Kühlschrank.
Das geht auch.
[Musik]
Es hat geklappt.
Aber man muss beim Ausrollen bedacht ausrollen,
mit Bedacht ausrollen.
Okay.
Das kommt jetzt auch zur Kühlung.
Und dann werde ich aus dem Rest
einfach ein Rechteck ausrollen und kleine Kekse ausstechen.
Ihr könnt
– oh! Ich mache Sterne.
Ja, Sterne.
[Musik]
Jetzt reicht es nicht mehr für Sterne,
jetzt mache ich noch ein paar Streifen.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin die Resteverwerterin schlechthin.
Bis zum letzten Rest wird hier ausgerollt
und geguckt, was man noch verwerten kann.
Also bei mir wird auch tatsächlich
kein einziger Mürbeteigrest weggeschnitten
– weggeschmissen.
Weggeschnitten ja.
Und beim Rest, den ich dann nicht mehr ausrollen kann,
zeige ich euch.
Zack!
Ich meine, das könnte man jetzt schon noch einmal, oder?
Aber bei dem Rest mache ich es dann so:
Da mache ich einfach so kleine
Kügelchen,
drücke sie flach
und dann wird es einfach mitgebacken und direkt genascht.
Da kommt nichts weg.
Ich kenne nämlich voll viele
– der Josh lacht jetzt hinter der Kamera.
Aber ich kenne voll viele, die so einen kleinen Rest,
auch beim Plätzchenbacken,
dann einfach wegschmeißen.
Und ich denke immer so: Das ist auch Essen.
Und roh essen will ich es jetzt auch nicht.
Also wird es gebacken und dann gegessen.
Der kalte Teig, die kalte Form wird dann praktisch gebacken.
Nach dem Backen lasse ich alles abkühlen.
Und dann
– da ein bisschen darauf achten, dass er sich nicht verbiegt.
Und dann kann es direkt weiter verarbeitet werden
nach dem Abkühlen.
[Musik]
Jetzt bereite ich mal noch die Deko vor.
Hier habe ich ja schon meine Sterne.
Die sind recht schön.
Ich nehme noch Oliven,
eine rote Paprika,
Frühlingszwiebeln,
– Frühlingszwiebeln im Winter –
Radieschen
und Käse.
Beim Käse habe ich jetzt einfach einen Cheddar.
Den werde ich auch gleich wie die Sternchen
zu Sternen ausstechen.
Und alles, was jetzt hier gleich übrig bleibt
an Lebensmittelresten,
das kommt bei mir alles gleich mit in einen Salat.
Also auch da kommt nichts weg.
[Musik]
So. Dann gibt es halt später Salat mit Cheddar.
Sodele.
Bei der Paprika mache ich es so, dass ich sie,
ja, wie so kleines Konfetti aussteche.
Also es soll dann auch wie so kleine Kügelchen aussehen.
Ich denke, mit einer Lochtülle geht das ganz gut.
Ich glaube, so für Weihnachten
kann man so Spielereien machen.
[Musik]
Die Frühlingszwiebeln,
ich glaube, da nehme ich nur ein bisschen was vom Grün
und schneide das jetzt ganz normal in Ringe.
Das nehme ich für den Salat.
[Musik]
Und jetzt noch das Wichtigste:
Rosmarin.
Den habe ich fast vergessen.
[Musik]
Jetzt bin ich eigentlich schon so weit und kann
die Torte zusammensetzen.
Ich finde es komisch, Torte,
weil es halt herzhaft ist.
Ich fülle sie jetzt mit einem Spritzbeutel ein,
nehme dafür eine große Lochtülle.
[Musik]
Und wenn ihr die Spitze hier so hochklappt,
dann kommt unten auch erst mal nichts raus.
Und ich glaube fast,
ich habe es zu gut gemeint mit der Creme.
Aber ist nicht schlimm.
Josh, dann manchen wir so einen Feinkostladen auf.
>> JOSH: Wir brauchen ja auch noch Dips für die Reste.
>> SALLY: Ja, eben.
Weil ich werde
– oh ja, ich werde die Paprika, die rote, noch zerkleinern.
Dann haben wir doch noch unseren
– meinen heiß geliebten Paprikadip.
Jetzt muss ich euch etwas gestehen.
Ich habe den einen Boden zerstört.
Den ich habe ihn, als er warm war,
da hoch bewegt.
Und das dürft ihr echt nicht.
Also ihr müsst die komplett abkühlen lassen.
Und dann aber
– der ist jetzt an drei Stellen gebrochen leider.
Aber ich nehme den jetzt
– er ist jetzt an fünf Stellen gebrochen.
Aber ich werde den jetzt einfach als Boden nehmen
und wir werden schweigen.
Geht.
Man sieht es gleich nicht mehr.
Aber es war natürlich sehr schade und ich habe fast geweint.
Es war fast genauso ein Unfall wie
mit Murat und dem Rasierapparat.
Ja. Er wollte, dass ich ihm die Haare schneide,
und ich bin mit dem Rasierapparat abgerutscht.
Ups!
Okay.
Jetzt nehme ich die Füllung,
halte den Spritzbeutel so senkrecht
und jetzt kommt das Ganze praktisch als Tupfen
hier drauf.
Und wenn ich es nicht besser wüsste,
würde ich echt sagen, das ist so ein Gingerbread Cake
mit einer Vanillekipferlcreme.
[Musik]
Hier die innere Linie spritze ich dann auch noch.
Und hier innen, muss ich sagen, spare ich mir die Tupfen
– denn die sieht man ja dann wirklich nicht mehr –
und fülle es einfach mit der Restcreme aus.
Ich weiß noch, ich habe das früher auch immer noch getupft.
Aber da denke ich mir echt so:
Es sieht kein Mensch.
[Musik]
Probier ruhig.
>> SAMIRA: Das ist so
knoblauchig.
>> SALLY: Du hast jetzt gedacht,
das ist eine süße Creme, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe gedacht,
dass das eben so Käse ist oder so was
und dass das Erdbeeren sind.
>> SALLY: Das wird eine Vorspeise.
Aber schmeckt es?
>> SAMIRA: Na ja.
>> SALLY: Wenn man auf herzhaft eingestellt ist,
schmeckt es, gell?
Ach Gott!
Jetzt kommt hier die zweite Schicht,
die ich hoffentlich nicht zerbreche.
Ja.
Ich habe sie nicht zerbrochen.
>> SAMIRA: Ist das vorhin zerbrochen?
>> SALLY: Minimal. An fünf Stellen.
Aber ich habe mir das so gedacht,
dass jeder dann denken wird, es ist süß.
Okay. Und da kommen jetzt die Tupfen auch drauf
und da natürlich auch komplett.
Denn jetzt sieht man es ja.
[Musik]
Und jetzt nehme ich hier die Lebensmittel
und dekoriere, ja, einfach
den Tannenbaum schön.
So ein bisschen Rosmarin.
Dann die Sternchen.
Also ein Stern muss ja auf jeden Fall
da oben hin.
Ja.
[Musik]
So gefällt es mir schon richtig gut.
Damit man es gut durchschneiden kann,
sollte es auch am besten über Nacht ziehen.
Also ihr könnt es wirklich schon am Tag vorher zubereiten.
Wir werden jetzt gleich noch Fotos machen.
Ich werde hier aufräumen.
Das heißt, da kann es dann
auch noch ein bisschen durchziehen.
Und dann werden wir probieren.
Und ich glaube,
ich werde den Murat und Josh probieren lassen.
Denn beide haben gesagt, das wäre jetzt nicht so ihr Fall
und sie können es sich nicht vorstellen.
Aber allein optisch finde ich es schon richtig cool.
Ob jetzt für einen Weihnachtsbrunch oder einfach so
oder als Vorspeise,
ich finde das eine coole Idee.
Wir werden sehen, ob sie gut ankommt geschmacklich.
Hier werde ich jetzt noch die übrige Creme,
wie gesagt, verarbeiten einmal mit der Paprika.
Und dann kann ich
so eine richtig schöne Antipasti-Platte richten.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Schneiden wir jetzt den Kuchen an?
>> SALLY: Ja, wir schneiden jetzt den Kuchen an.
Und der Papa und der Josh, die dürfen...
>> ELA: Das ist kein Kuchen.
>> SALLY: Aber es sieht schon aus wie ein Kuchen, oder?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Was ist es dann?
>> ELA: Ein Nachtisch.
>> MURAT: So.
Dann probiere ich jetzt auch mal.
>> SALLY: Ja, ihr zwei, ihr seid ja die Skeptiker.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber was sagt ihr jetzt rein optisch?
>> MURAT: Rein optisch würde ich sofort...
>> JOSH: Hammer, oder?
>> MURAT: Ich würde es einfach eher für ein Ding halten,
für was Herzhaftes
– Süßes.
>> SALLY: Für so einen Nachtisch, nicht?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> JOSH: Echt? Aber die Frühlingszwiebel, die ist doch...
>> MURAT: Ja, ja. Aber ich gucke da gar nicht auf so Details.
>> JOSH: Ach so. Okay.
>> MURAT: Ich sehe nur Essen.
Dann gehe ich hin und schnappe zu.
Ich bin da eiskalt wie ein Alligator.
>> JOSH: Okay. Ja. Haben wir schon Gabeln?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> JOSH: Okay, ich hole Gabeln.
>> MURAT: Brauchen wir auch nicht,
weil das ist ein Fingerfood, Josh.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Nein...
Ja, okay.
>> JOSH: Ja, okay. Komm.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Achtung, Ela.
>> MURAT: Mh.
>> JOSH: Oder so.
>> ELA: Das sind Radieschen.
>> MURAT: Mh.
>> JOSH: Danke.
>> MURAT: Den kann ich doch nicht so essen!
>> SALLY: Ja, den Rosmarin brauchst du jetzt nicht mitessen.
>> MURAT: Ja, aber...
Josh, pass auf den Rosmarin auf.
Ich hatte gerade einen ganzen Baum im Mund.
>> SALLY: Und?
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ela, wie schmeckt es dir?
>> ELA: Super.
Oh!
>> JOSH: Und was meinst du, Murat?
>> MURAT: Hammer!
>> JOSH: Gut?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> JOSH: Echt? Bist du überzeugt?
>> SALLY: Du?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Du bist eher der Süße, gell?
>> JOSH: Die süße Variante, ich bleibe dabei.
>> MURAT: Ehrlich?
>> JOSH: Muss ich echt sagen. Ja, ganz ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Also ich finde es cool so.
>> MURAT: Man kann ja noch
– man könnte es noch voll aufpimpen. Man könnte noch
>> SALLY: Jetzt sag bitte nicht Sucuk.
>> MURAT: als Bodenbelag Wurst drauf machen.
>> JOSH: Dann...
>> MURAT: Wurst oder Lachs oder so was.
Dann kommt es richtig cool.
>> SALLY: Ich habe sogar tatsächlich überlegt,
eine Lachscreme zu machen.
Aber ich dachte: Komm, jetzt machen wir es mal so.
Ihr könnt es ja im Prinzip abwandeln, wie ihr wollt.
Probiert gerne die herzhafte Variante aus
oder geht auf meinen Blog und in meine App
und probiert die süße Variante aus.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also so die Variante mit Lebkuchenboden
und Bratapfel
>> JOSH: Oh ja!
>> SALLY: und Zimt ist natürlich auch lecker.
>> JOSH: Das wäre schon auch cool.
>> SALLY: Ihr könnt ja mal in die Kommentare schreiben,
ob eher herzhaft oder süß.
Also ich finde, so ist echt was Tolles
fürs Frühstück oder, wie gesagt, auch als Vorspeise.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Viel Spaß!
>> JOSH: Lecker ist es auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Hm. Viel Spaß!
>> MURAT: Wenn man den ganzen Tag Zeit hat,
dann geht das schon.
>> SALLY: Nee, das ging jetzt voll schnell.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also es ging echt schnell.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also dann viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal.
>> MURAT & SALLY: Tschüss!
>> JOSH: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Da fehlt noch...
>> SALLY: Aber geschmeckt hat es, nicht?
>> JOSH: Ja, es ist superlecker. Aber ich bin
>> SALLY: So optisch.
>> JOSH: bei so was eher so...
>> MURAT: Ich finde, da kann man
noch so Sucuk-Stücke reinmachen.
>> JOSH: Ich freue mich da auf was...
Ja, dann wäre es
– das wäre dann was anderes.
>> MURAT: Sucuk. Oh, da könnte man noch...
>> SALLY: Ach jemine!
Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Ach, Volkan, das ist kein Problem.
Steh vor die Kamera, Volkan.
>> SALLY: Egal.
>> MURAT: No problem.
>> SALLY: Ein schöner Rücken kann auch entzücken.
>> MURAT: It's okay, Volkan.
But it's not...
O mein Gott!
>> JOSH & MURAT: Volkan!
>> JOSH: Volkan randaliert.
>> MURAT: It's not vegan, aber it's okay.
Frohe Weihnachten!
Tschüss!
>> JOSH: Frohe Weihnachten!
[Musik]